Oh, shit...
Ah, what did I do?? I just started!
Oh!
Well, ain't that lovely!
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to "No Man's Sky!"
Now, I've been doing a lot of stuff.
Mostly farming.
Because I discovered that this gun that I got?
It's even more cool than I thought it was.
Haboosky!
*nothing happens*
*feels stupid*
*Laughs* Hang on wait a second...
Haboosky...
There we go!
That's what I uh, discovered. And *laughs* it's really awesome!
But, apparently, the drones around here don't
like it very much, as they'll come over here-
-inspect the crash site, if I do it too much,
and then attempt to blow me away!
Which is not good.
But this is actually a different outpost, uh, from where I was before.
I've got a bunch of materials.
Um...
And this is actually a different gun than
the one I had before,
because I went to this other outpost and
there was another gun available here that
was even better than the first gun!
And it's even got two extra slots that
I can put, like, more stuff into.
Like, make my plasma launcher, which is this bad boy over here, even better than it already is,
and it's already pretty dang good,
and it's just charged up by Carbon, of all things.
So, this is super fun!
I'm having a great time just farming up materials! =D
Like, what kinda strange-ass game is that fun??
I don't know.
But I'm gonna go into space now because,
I need to build the hyperspace module.
And I don't know exactly how to do that,
but we're gonna damn sure find out!
...If we can get up there.
With our boosty-boost!
Uuuaaaaah!
Okay, there we go
Not quite as fast as it needs to be.
♪Eeeeeey!♪
Alright, theeere we are!
That's navigating a bit better!
So what we need to do, is we need to get over
to the space station, and I believe that we have enough materials.
And the interesting thing is; the "planet" that we were on is actually a moon to THAT planet.
Which is waaay bigger than the planet that we were just on.
But it's weird, because I wonder if all of these planets
are hospitable.
Habitable.
Either one of those words whichever is more correct.
I wonder if that's how this works.
And that, I believe, is the original-- yeah!
That's Fffeigheso...Niz... IZdik!
I shoulda renamed that one just to plant "Izdik"
because that would've been better.
But anyway, we need to pulse-jump over here, and let's hope that this doesn't turn ♪scary!!♪
Which it usually does when I make a pulse-jump *excited*
uueah.
I can't even imagine what it's gonna be like to do a hyper-drive jump!
Eeeaaah, shitty!!
Stop
STOP!
AAAAH!
Ohkay, alright, that's *excited nervous laughing*
terribly scary! I don't know why that's so scary.
I didn't even get a good look at this thing!
That is a nice space station-- OH, I like
your under-balls there!
Ah, that's very nice.
It's okay that you got just one.
Aright, here we go!
Is it-- *hears annoying sound*
Is that an alarm?
*Sound dissipates*
Is that bad?
I guess it's okay...
Alright, fine then.
You know, I do wonder...
*a wild professor Mark appears*
... where did my character come from?
Like, what species is my character that the Vy'keen
seem very strange.
I mean, the Vy'keen seem to be inhabiting pretty
much everywhere in the entire universe.
But... who am I?
*existential crisis*
Who is me?
It's not just a question you--
I'm- I'm honestly curious, like who is me.
And the other thing that I'm gonna do, is I'm
gonna talk to this doodad-y here because-
-my ship is the beginner ship, it's also very
small (like you (^_−)☆) so what I want--
... Your ship looks kinda cool.
Uhh...
Are they about the same? Nah,
*uncertain*
... This one looks different. I'm gonna go
over to this one because I actually like the look.
And I discovered how to run, *laughs* which is
awfully nice!
You hold- you press the R1 button once, so...
Hello! Hi, neighbor!
Lovely ship you h-eeeuuuhh!
Anyway, I'm a close ally of the Vy'keen now,
whatever the hell that means.
Okay,
So, I wanna... I wanna make an offer on his spaceship, because I believe-
-that if I get another spa-- yeah! It's got tons and tons-- UAAAAAAAH!!!!!
Three Million???
( go farm)
THREE MILLION????
(farm your heart out)
I don't have that???
What kinda- what do you think I am?
(A farmer)
Made o' money??
Man, I shoulda been farming more.
Okay, so that's not gonna work obviously.
Alright, so, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go up there.
And I'm gonna build this hyperdrive, and then go
to another planet, and hopefully-
-by exploring more, I'm going to be able to
get a lot more money.
Cause that's all I care about.
Also, someone said something about... if you melee while you jetpack it makes you go fast.
But I don't wanna exploit it!
I don't wanna do exploits to get places.
Something about games like this, you wanna
take your time and just-
take in all the lovely environment and experience it all in one big beautiful thing!
Hello!
Ah, another trade terminal - what do I need from you?
*Fatherly instinct jumps in*
*at Chica* Quiet down, puppy. It oké.
Chica is over there making a bit of noise.
Okay, so
I'm assuming you want me to buy something.
Aah!
Are these the things that I'm gonna need?
I'm assuming they've got, stars by them
for a reason.
Yeah, because- oh, that's right I needed Heridium
and I'm guessing I need one of these.
Automaton voice: Product received.
Alright!
So I neeeed...
Maximum of thirty-one?
*Markimoo is not pleased*
Is that all you have??
I didn't farm up enough Heridium for this!
*not pleased at all*
Well that's a load of a--  what is Cry-so-nite?
Okay, let me actually see in the crafting menu--
Uuuh, as far as the ship...
*Finish your goddamn sentences!*
*thoughtfully* So, if I were to..... install tech....
"Dynamic Resonator"...
how
does
one
make
that!??
how--
how do you...
Well, there's a power reservoir, but is
that something that I need for the-- WHAT?
Okay, I'm confused.
I didn't quite look up what I-- I thought it was
going to tell me what I needed to do, but
apparently this is...
How the frick to I make a...
Well I don't have that recipe!
Do I?
I don't!
Hey, can you tell me exactly what I need to do?
I don't know how to make the hyperdrive =(
You're gonna give me some advice maybe?
And why do they all think that I'm an interloper,
what am I that I--
"Request New Word"
How bout this?
Hello!
Yaaay! He agrees to help me!
"Ancients"! Okay!
So you guys aren't the ancients is the thing...
Okay, so; what this tells me is that--
"Earning units" Oooooooh~!
Aaaaah!
Now it wants me to farm up stuff does it do that,
because I could go to a new planet and then
be able to do stuff about that.
So.
My imagination-- oh, "Dynamic Resonator"!
That's the thing that I needed!
I can buy that!
Okay cool!
And then I needed more Heridium, okay--
So I need Heridium--
But there's not enough Heridium here.
So what I'm gonna need to do is I may need to go get Heridium, and I can kill two birds with one stone-
-by discovering a new planet at the same time.
And, hopefully, not smash into the side of it
when I'm using my pulse-boost!
Ho-hoho my dinky little ship over there!
It is kinda tiny I need a bigger-- Haw,
Look at THAT one!
Aw, that's so cool!
*calls out* I'll be able to afford it eventually!
Because apparently all you aliens are just
waiting for a buyer to come along for your ship!
I mean, what if I did that for someone's car.
Just like, randomly decided to make an offer on
someone's Toyota outside in LA.
I mean, would they go for it?
Holy crap! That thing is TINY by comparison!
And that looks like a, predominantly water-planet-- LET'S GO FIND IT!
I CAN'T WAIT!
Yeeeaaah!
Don't crash into it, please!
Oh god
Oh gawd
Oh, God
Ah, too close-- DISENGAGE!
Whoa...
Okay!
Nice!
So, yeah, I need a hundred-and-sixty-nine
more Heridium,
And I'm willing to bet-- whoa! Okay, that
is weird. Alright it's just, loading in!
Whoooa...
Whueeey!♪
*auctioner voice* Boosting, boosting, boosting. Entering atmosphere. Probably gonna blow up at any moment here.
Alright, so I THINK I remember
what Heridium looked like.
It was a big, blue block. Basically.
*Applauds alliteration*
So all I gotta do is look for a big blue block
around here some-whoa!
You guys seein' that?
What is THAT?
Hello...?
Let me do a little scan-y-scan
Oh! That's definitely Heridium.
Alright, I'm gonna plop down there first,
get that Heridium-
-and then I'm gonna check out
what that giant obelisk-looking structure is.
♪Aaaaand
thrEe
twOo
One!
♪Landing!♪
There's something over there.
I like it (ツ)
I'll fly over there in a bit.
Ooooh and Plutonium!
Thank you!!
Oh wait,  my inventory is full. Shit.
Alright, hang on.
Deledledledle! *imitating music*
Come on.
Come on!!
Let me get to the menu.
I know; it's a new planet. Whoop-dee-fricken-doo.
I'm not 100% worried about that.
Okay, ah CRAP! That's right, I had the
shielding shard.
Um...
I don't think I need that right now?
Oh, that's right I can use the Power Reservoir
to fuel some systems.
I don't know if I can do it for this, but
at least I can-- get that Thamium9
in there.
Uuuuuh, shit.
I'm just running low on space is the thing.
I'm gonna destroy this because that's gonna be
easy to get.
They're not exactly expensive, but I AM gonna
hold on to this.
Send that over...
Send over the uncompleted stack.
Okay! Now that should be enough.
And now! Haboosky-WHOA!
That was weird.
"Reload"?
What???
"Reload"???
Whoa- does this have a gun?????
Oooooh!
It has gun!
*Well, dunk me in milk and call me a biscuit, a gun!*
*Needs to shoot gun*
*Shoots gun*
*Not TOO impressed.*
*Wait... grenade launcher...?*
*Meh*
It *laughs* It still has the same grenade launcher!
Something tells me that the destructive capacity
of the mining laser is pretty much equivalent to
what I had over here.
But I don't kno-- ooh, new planet!
New stuff to explore!
Sorry! Meant to analyse you
not blow you up.
What did that-- Oh, okay.
Oh! That's interesting
Alright, hang on, I'm gonna go
analyse some stuff.
Theeen, I'm gonna get the Heridium.
And theeeeen I'm gonna do all the stuff
that I need to do.
Ooh, big dick-like structure.
Alright.
Haboink!
Ooh, there's a drone-y over there!
I'm not gonna bother him-- Wait!
Was that THAT far off from the Heridium??
Well how was I that far off I don't
remember being that far off??
That's a bunch of-- Ah! I
WASN'T that far off.
Okay.
There's tons of Heridium around here.
Alright, here we go!
Haboosky!
Haboosky!!
Heeelllll *fucking reload making me look bad*
Haboosky!
Thank you!
Alright.
It's a good amount of Heridium, not exactly
everything that I needed it to be.
Elelela
I think the grenade launcher is actually better
for like uh, breaking down um, like trees and rocks
and stuff.
Because it's got high instantaneous damage.
But uh, you know, the mining laser is better for this
which just breaks apart like easily.
Infobot: Life support is low.
Mark: How is it already low???
Is this-- whoa!
Is this place like heavily toxic or something?
Huh.
Okay.
So now, I should be able to-- Yuess!
Yessh!
YES!
Infobitch: Technology installed.
YES!!!
Can I move that? Oh shit, I probably should have
put that up there where everything else was.
Okay... it needs a warp cell??
Where do I get a Warp Cell?
Well THAT'S an interesting idea but-- ooh,
Hello!
Don't min-heh-don't mind me!
It was like this when I got here!
I didn't do anything! ଘ(੭*ˊᵕˋ)੭*
Okay, bye!
Alright, so
Let's see.
What else do we have over here.
Hello, big bulbous thing!
"Ku-hen-romite!" Okay?
Fine by me.
... Where did my ship go?
Oh there it is.
Hang on, there's a supply drop over here.
Lemme just see-- Oh!
Wait a minute.
What is THAT?
What IS that?
That looks like the broken down thing that the
red glowing orb was in.
And boy howdy, I sure found the Heridium deposits!
I might go over and farm those up anyway,
but that looks like...
What are you?
Hello?
Oh, you're a trading terminal!
Ah! A personality core-- that is 100% a
personality core!
That is 100% a Portal 2 personality core
You can not. Convince me. That it is not.
100% is.
Alright, power canister, Fascination beads...
I do not have an AtlassPass.
But I CAN save here!
Kerchunkers-- MAN, it's just the land of Heridium!
Unlimited Heridium.
Oh, and LOTS of Plutonium.
I like this planet.
*southern accent* This planet is vury naice.
Heh!
Is a weird gold, dubble ended dildo over there.
Alright, so lemme sell off some stuff
that I got.
Wow, my life support is going down very quickly.
That is definitely uh, due to the volatile nature
of this planet.
So I'm gonna need to--
Alright, so sell the Fascination Bead,
I'm gonna use the Power Canister to fuel
my stuff.
I've got extra Heridium but,
frankly I think I need it.
Okay
I don't have enough to sell.
Alright, bye-bye-bye I gotta go.
Cause apparently my health is deteriorating
rapidly.
And then I'm gonna-- I need to
doolidoo-doodloodoo-doodoo
*You need to WHAT???*
Dayum, that is going down so fast!
Glados II: Technology recharged
I know right, cool huh?
Okay, gotta go, gotta go, gotta go.
Why is it-- OH! "19.4 toxicity" rating?
Would there be any native species on this
*says something unintelligible*
I don't even know
How would anyone know?
GeroniMiooooooooooooooo! !!!
Okay.
HEH!
So I have the hyperdrive, but I need warp cells.
And I don't know where the hell to get warp cells.
Ice queen: Navigational data received.
Ahuh? To what?
Was there a colony out here, who the
hell would be living here??
Alright, I gotta go to this big
obelisk thing, because this is bizarre.
*Southerner/Indian sound effects*
What is THAT?
The "Leche Lowlands".
What are these-- that's bizarre.
*Hears unknown animal sound*
Eugh.. okay...
"Jettison Pod".
"Power Canister"; not needed.
Ah! "Convergence Cube"!
Those are uh,
you can really sell those for a lot of money.
And what is these?
I can destroy them?? For titanium??
Well that wasn't enough titanium to warrant that.
OH god dammit!
Oh, come on, I didn't mean to
*AHEM, yes you did*
Alright, I'm gonna switch to the gun, here.
Hoooly crap, it's got auto targetting! =D
Oh my god!
That is supremely effective! (╭ರᴥ•́)
"Boltcaster Clip Sigma already known."
Alright.
So, that's that, but where is-- Ah! There it is.
What is that?
What's with the big obelisk?
OOH! "Vy'keen dagger"!
HoHO! "GekNip"!
I don't know what that is, but
I'll take it.
So what the hell-- what is that?
Is that just a bigass thing of Heridium?
Why would there be a big obe-- WHOA!
Hoooly crap, there's some stuff over here!
Oh, so pretty!
GPS voice: Life Support Power, Low
Yeah, I get it, I get it; it's very toxic here,
I need to go home.
Whoa...
Oooh, that's a big thing of Plutonium!
OOOH-kay.
Sex bot: Free slots in suit inventory
I know, I know I know. I got to get these
over to the-- *noise*
Dammit!
*Frustrated sigh*
I don't need the Power Canister.
But this is probably worth a lot-- yeah,
twenty thousand.
Kay, this is worth twenty thousand.
Twenty-seven thousand!! That's a lot of money.
I might have to go back to that uh, one shop-keep.
*rubber band noise*
I might as well get this Plutonium-- this is just Heridium!??
That's all this is it's a giant thing of Heridium!
But WHY?
Oh, is that the space station up there? Cooool!
Cooool!
Huh-oh!
I'm not-- I'm not doing anything, I'm just
mining Heridium.
What's that, a crime?
What is that a crime!
HUH!?
I'm fine.
Move along!
That's right, move along.
Heh
Hyeh!
HEH-EH!
Alright, that should be enough Heridium
for now, anyway.
Alright! So now, we gotta find where the warp
coils *lol* are, and I'm wondering
if it's- if it's marking this outpost
for a particular reason, then it's definitely
got warp coils out there.
That's, my imagination, right?
Probably?
Heerrraaaw!
Maybe I should do a pulse-jump over there.
That be smart, right?
Probably not.
*seriously considering pulse jump*
Yeah, let's not do that.
I mean, I made a lot of bad decisions in
my life, but-- Ooh! Whoa!
Hello??
Hello, hello! Are you knowledge?
Ooh, I'd stop for knowledge!
Oh, it is knowledge!!
It might be a LOT of knowledge,
what is this?
Cookie (wait, what?)
Cookie!
(This can't be what he says, help.)
I'm gonna learn another word!
Maybe?
Knowledge.
"Warrior" Okay!
And then whatever the hell THIS thing is.
Whoa, is that another knowledge-- Oh my god!
Oh!
Cool!
Oh, sweet!
Wow, I found something big!
Oh, and what's this?
Ooh...
Can you- can you get the achievement
pain out of the way I need to- I'm learning things!
Leave me alone!
Okay, thank you
Okay, what is this.
"Monolith".
"Interact"?
Oh, is it above?
Oh! Inventory full.
Okay, okay okay okay, I know.
I need to charge these anyway, so.
Oh, NOT THE PLUTONIUM!
Aaaaagh, my Plutonium...
I think I also need to stack up my Plutonium.
Infochan: Technology recharged
I know, I know, I know.
Soooo, yeaaaah.
Okay.
Got enough Heridium.
*inhales deeply*
Life support, yeah, that's what I gotta do
What that didn't use all of it??
Ah, dangit.
Okay,
But at least I got one other spot.
And then, hopefully, I'll be able to
sell things at the outpost.
Whoa!
Cool.
Aw, I should have been standing on THAT.
Oh whoops *calls out* I'm underneath it,
don't worry about me!
"I place my palm... *reads text*
"Dom Vy'keen anciets cogon hermemni rudo lepinggu."
I'm willing to bet, this is a test.
This is a test!
I'll stand back.
I don't need to burn my hand off.
"The ancient warriors once worshipped here
bless my show of respect".
HaHA!
I got it right *smug*
You don't steal riches that are obviously surrounded
by molten lava.
I learned anoth-- OH, I learned another word!
Am I he-- OOOOOh!
Naiiice!
Any other stones that I might have missed?
Learned the word for "awake".
I got a effigy!?
Ooooooooh!
I'm learnin' so much!
Yeah!
"Confused" *laughs* You're damn right I'm confused!
And I'm PROUD of being confuuuused.
Man, so that's really cool.
So, if I was to explore like the entirety of this
planet, how many of those things were there?
Is that like super rare and I found the only one?
I don't- I don't believe that for a second but,
it made me feel good if it was!
AH, it's so cool, though!
There's so much to explOoOoOre!!
*exhilarated laugh*
*Darkiplier ended it*
Alright
Boosting!
Haboosky!
Alright, where are we headed now?
Keepin' an eye out for any strange obelisk
type devices-- whoa.
Ah! What is that?
HOly shit!
Whoa...
It's ANOTHER one!
Ah, shit. Whoops!
Alright!
Probably gonna have another test of endurance
over here.
Or test of will or whatever you wanna call it.
I'M GONNA BE TESTED. *Period*
And I'm learnin' a lotta words!
I mean how-- "coil".
How many words do you think are in this
language here?
Probably thousands, if it's anything
like English.
That's a weird thing to think about everyday,
you know, how many individual words do we use
on a daily basis
and yet we're able to recall them with absolute
certainty at any time.
God dammit-- alright I' m gonna drop...
"Crolium". OH SHIT, I need to sell that.
Um...
What do I have extra of...
Iron!
There's no way I'd need Iron,
I don't need that.
I can get that anywhere.
Oh, it wants to give me a whole bunch
of stuff, does it? Okay.
So...
Yeah, I don't need Iron, I don't need Carbon.
I can get rid of these.
*Are you suuuuuuuuure?*
*Too late now.*
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Oh no, that's right. I emptied my ship out, duh!
Okay, but this is fine.
Hello! "I'm trying to read the glyphs on the ancient momyment when I feel a strange chill."...
*Realization kicks in*
AAAAaoooooh come on!
I just got rid of my Carbon!
Alright fine! I'll be right back!
I'll go get some goddamn Iron or Carbon or whatever would yo-- have you-- and of course there's nothing
nearby.
Gosh dang it!
Alright, I'll be right back.
Maybe I could fire a grenade into there.
Give me!
Ah, it's too far away to grab.
Well, shhhoot.
Infobot: Life support power; Low.
Ah, yeah yeah I don't care.
Okay! Iron Iron Iron.
That will be enough.
Whoo, that's gonna be a jump!
Alright, here we go.
HEH!
OH, make it, MAKE IT, mAkE iT, makeit, make it...
Make it!
OOOkay!
We made it.
Alright. Now I've got Iron, thanks so much for telling
me right before I destroyed everything!
That I need my god damn Iron! *your frustration is noticable*
Sack o' crap!
Aright.
Hebidehebebebeh. *instead of rereading passage*
How about oxide?
"My elements are not returned".
"There is silence."??
Well what does THAT mean?
Was it like a puzzle??
What did I...
*clicks around in vain*
Huh-oh.
Wha...
Ahhh!!!
I didn't read it clearly enough!
Oh, damn it!
Of course! I-- uuuuuugh!
Of COURSE I delete my Carbon, which
I didn't know I was gonna need right then and there!
Uh, that's- that's my fault.
That's on me.
Wait, are these Carbon?
Little bits o' Carbon?
Nah.
Alright, fine.
I failed that one, I can't be TOO smart.
Well, it still says it's there, I don't know
if that's important, though.
Aright, whatever I procrastinated too much.
Alright, let's get over here!
*hiss* I don't wanna stop at any other monoliths there's be plenty of time to explore other Monolith-th-thes.
When I'm, circumnavigating the entire
universe.
With which there is a LOT to circumnavigate.
And I'm gonna get there.
But yeah, I was thinking about language and
just the idea of having like, words crawling up-
I mean like obviously it's second nature and
obviously it's not too big of a deal, and
everyone is able to do it so quickly it's not-
-it's not like horrifyingly interesting or-or
unique idea.
But just like, common vinacular is a fascinating
subject, and you know; the ability to conjure up these
methods of communication-
-and how we as a species have developed stuff
it's- it's interesting to think about.
Hello! Hi friend!
*Lemme use my revered human communications skills on you*
How you doin'?
How you doin', buddy?
How's it going?
What can I do for yah?
Let's see; "Special relationship"
Ho-ho-ho!
Nope, didn't understand any of that.
"The being snarls at me..." *continues to read text*
*reading text on screen*
"... enough of it that I can build a WARP CELL"!!!!
Thank you!!
Whoever my benefactors are they sure do
care about me. (Who wouldn't lol) As an inte-- wha
"I am no wiser as to who Nada and Polo are, but now
I have the means to locate them I strongly"-- OH!
oH!
Thank you!
Thank you very much!
I appreciate that!
I'm gonna sell my crap cause I got too
much of it.
Alright, "Vy'keen Effigy"
"Vy'keen dagger" Uuuuuuh...
Let's see, I need to grap this stuff
from my ship.
Gimme two seconds.
Oh, one of these days I'm gonna learn the
direction that that goes.
Okay, transfer of this.
Whatever the hell "GekNip" is.
I don't- if it's anything like catnip, I
don't wanna know.
God-- ding-- OH FUCK! I don't know the
goddamn direction!
Okay, so I'm gonna toss this Heridium
over there.
♪Heridium♪
Her-
Her-- wha?
what?
Heridium- there we go!
I don't know why that all froze up.
Okay... Ummm...
And then...
Chromium...
(*Crolium)
And that should be enough to sell for now.
Okay!
So nOoOoOw
I aM gOiNg To SeLl...
... the Geknip!
The Chromium
(Em, Mark, "Crolium")
But NOT the antimatter.
And this.
Okay! Good good good!
Apparently I completed another journey
milestone, which is awfully nice.
Does this-- OH, this place...
OOOOOOOH!!
"Inversion of Bij... jayzio-Lahko".
I don't know what that means.
Ooooh...
That is a combat weapon!
Holy crap, is that a combat weapon.
I don't know if I need that, I-I-I like what
I got thus far.
You know, what with my adve-- identification
goggles and all and what-have-you.
Okay.
So now that I got that I nee--
Oh!
Thaaat is a weird ship...?
Now, I don't mean to criticize, but just...
... Little bizarre. If you ask me.
(Captionist approves of ship, though.)
Alright.
So anyway, I got tha-- "Not Alone. Met 4 aliens".
You're goddamn right I'm not alone I'm
Pffff!!!
I'm in the fricken surfing the stars!
*Laughs* "Space Trucker".
Yeh, that me.
*accent* Markiplier; the Shpace Truckr.
Goin thru the shtars with mah preshus cargo.
Lookn' fer, alien lifeforms to meet.
If yah know what A meayun.
No? Oh goddammit.
Kay, so we need fuel this up with Plutionium.
Alright, and then we need to... MAKE a
Warp Cell.
Thamium!!!!
Damn! Dammit! Damn! Dagnabit we gotta go
get Thamium.
Aright.
So where the hell am I gonna get Thamium
around here...?
Cause this area that I'm in, is not
exactly-- plant friendly.
I haven't seen a single plant since I
got here, so this planet is like,
very rich in minerals, but not rich in plant life
which is the only source of Thamium that I know of.
So I'm gonna neeeed
I'm gonna need to go to a different
planet I believe.
Before I'm able to do that.
So, I'm going toooo--
Go. Away.
(Captionist couldn't stop laughing at eloquence)
Goodbye~!
Oh, I can't pulse jump in the atmosphere.
Who'da thunked it.
huh?
Go, baby, go!
Hoh, HERE WE GO!
Ooooooh Hello!
Alright
WOW, we're goin fast!
I don't know where we're goin'.
Okay, hang on.
Stop stop stop!
STAAAWP, stop stop.
Stop!
There we go!
So I belieeeuuuEEEEUHOH-WHOA-OOOhkay...
So, that's my original planet and it's got tons
and tons of plant life.
I could get that for Thamium.
I don't know if there's any other planets in
the immediate range that I could go to...
Oh man, that is pretty...
OH, it's so pretty :3
*giddilly* Oh, it's so pretty
SO PRETTY.
I'm done freaking out for now but,
it's still pretty.
Aright.
So I'm gonna go back to Izdik.
And hopefully
I can get some Thamium really quickly and then
engage my Warp Drive to go to another star system.
Which is, I believe, the entire reason
we're doing this?
Probably?
Boy! It's-- it sure is lucky that I'm not hitting any of
these rocks as I go along, but you know.
Aright.
Come ooon, hurry up!
Hurry up!!
I ain't got all day!
Ugh! Space travel is such and arduous journey!
This is bullshit!
Why can't I be there already.
Also, the question is: this Pulse Drive... it can't be--
it's not faster than light travel, is it?
I wouldn't believe so, but then again...
NO nono, it wouldn't be.
Shuuuuweeeaaaahh
Okay.
So where am I headed?
Ah, home sweet home.
Wherever the hell this home is.
Okay.
So!
This all look like dry desert.
Where's all the uh...
Where's all the forests??
Man, I shoulda gone back to that moon, because
that moon had tons of forest.
But I remember there being Thamium here...
There definitely WAS.
So there definitely will BE.
ooh, what is that?
Hello!
What are you?
Oh you're just..
Alright, you're nothin'.
*heartbroken rock*
Alright.
Any Thamium here??
Ooh! I'm gonna stop by here.
Get some Carbon for this thing.
Actually READ before I do something.
And THEN go about my day.
Ah, this is looking better!
Alright, so I need Thamium...
So noooow...
I need to get the knowledge.
Nice!
"Thaws"??
Wooow.
This is gonna go-- this really is gonna go through the
whole ding-dong-dang language, isn't it?
Not that I'm opposed!!!
I am not opposed to that, I like
that very much.
I like in depth, when it comes to my games.
"Muddled", yeah, fifteen words.
Good for me!
Now get outta my face!
"Units"?
N'kay.
Now let's actually READ closely here.
*reads text above*
"... base of each column".
*Processing very hard*
*Not sure what to think*
*But finds it extremely interesting*
Uuuum...
Is this just random?
*lost* The letters???
(crosses fingers)
HOOOOOOOOAH!
"Beaked Traders"???
Hoooah!
Oh! So that was just a choice.
It gave me the lang-- Oh!
GEK!!??
Whose the "Gek"???
High five??
"Atlas"????
(Are you feeling it now, Mr Krabbs?)
I didn't know there were other languageses
apart of this???
Holy crap, I had no idea!
Alright, so that's besides the point.
I need, THAT!
I need that right there!
I need THAMIUM! And lots of it!
Give me your goddam-- Couldn't I just have bought
it from a store?
Am I that dumb-- am I dumb?
(You most certainly are NOT)
I'm dumb.
Well, I know I am dumb, but...
(Liar xD)
Am I that dumb that I didn't even think
to buy it from a store.
Eeeeh, I'm pretty dumb.
Aright, whatever, it gave me an excuse
to go back and redeem myself for my stupidity.
*Seance voice* Alright, Thamium, Thamium, come on out.
Thamium, Thamium, show me your butt!
Thamium, Thamium, please tell me,
*devolved into a rhyme voice*
Thamium, Thamium where the fuck you be!
Where the fffffff
frick it be!
Huh!
Where that gauddamn thaumium a'.
Whered all theh Thamium!
What the hell doeth Thamium thinkin hiding
from me!
Well that not Thamium!
Go to hell!
"Aluminium"?
Weeell, I guess it's close.
Where's the Thamium...
Alright, I gotta...
I gotta fly.
I gotta fly and, I'm willing to bet that
I can buy Thamium from a store.
That would've been... That would have been
infinitely smarter. So lemme go ahead and-
-do that because this is-- I expected to have this
hyperdrive up and running way before this.
Ahhh, I gotta get more Plutonium for
the launch thrusters.
Can I shoot?
How do I shoot?
Whooo, that ain't how shoot.
Ah!! THAT's how I shoot!
Can I collect gold?
Like this?
Please?
No? Okay.
Alright, so where would an outpost be....
More importantly where would an out-- OOOOH!
Here we go!
Here we are.
Does it have a landing pad?
Is this something that I can actually
go into?
Huh
I wanna say "no" it didn't look like it have a
landing pad-- Ooh!
What about this one?
Ah, this looks a little more promis-- there we go!
That's what I'm lookin' for.
Aright
Aaaaand, right on target!
Nice.
I did it.
So how-- they probably have Thamium.
Hello!
Hi friend!
Okay, don't mind me.
I'm just gonna... Take your thing.
Take your thing, okay.
Good enough for me.
Don't mind me, I just stole your stuff!
Not important, don't worry about it.
Okay, so I need to buuyyyy...
Yeah, I can't believe I completely forgot
that I can totally buy stuff.
Yeah, they have Thamium. Okay,
so I need-- OH! They don't have ENOUGH Thamium.
That's a problem.
Oh, I forgot I can hold it down.
Okay, so.
Okay, so that's not enough Thamium, but it's get-- it's
definitely getting me closer.
Whoooooa!
Hello! Whoo!
It's white delight!
Ooh, what are you.
Ooooooooh, you look cool!!
Ooooh, you look cool!!!
Oh--- I don't need it!!!
*bursts everyone's bubble*
I don't need to waste my money on that stuff.
I really don't.
I know I really WANT to,
I WANNA go shopping for cool new guns and stuff.
Ooh,
Okay, lemme just sell these real quick, because
otherwise my inventory is gonna be stocked full.
Oh, man... I WANNA buy all this stuff, but I wanna save
up for a ship with more storage capacity.
Because, Goddammit, I need it so badly.
Goodbye, Fascination Bead, don't need you...
Uuuuuuh bababababa-- Zinc...
I don't have enough to sell, but might as
well get rid of it!
I-I didn't wanna keep that little amount in my inventory
just because, you know, I don't want it to take up spots.
How do increase the inventory of my storage on
my person?
Like, that's what I really wanna know because,
if I could just figure that out then I'd have a better un--
*pause and sighs*
better grasp on everything that I needed.
Okay, so we're looking for Thamium.
Where the heck that Thamium at?
Wheeere it aaatt?
Show yourself, is it gonna be in this
forest area?
I bet it is~!
I bet there's Thamium in there.
Aright, I'm gonna-- I'm gonna stop here.
Cause I just need a little more!!
It's not much!!
Just a little Thamium is all I ask!
That better not be Plutonium.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Okay, I'm willing to bet there's a lot of Plutonium
in that cave system over there, but that's not what
I'm going for.
Aaaauauh, more milestones!
Ah, there we go!
Thamium!
Thamium! *my love!*
YES, is that enough?
Did I get enough?
Ooh, did I get enough...?
Maybe maybe? i'm gonna get this just in ca-
YEAAAH!! I CAN MAKE IT!
OOH, I can fuel my Hyperdrive~!
I can fuel it! ♪
Okay.
So I need to craft...
This!
Okay.
And then, get back to my ship.
*laughs* I'm trying to figure out the thing that they
were talking about.
uuuh...
Aaaah!!
THAT's how you do it!
Okay, that make sense! okay.
That makes sense. Kind of like a... a rocket.
A rocket boost.
"Warp cell"
Well, that wasn't a lot but I'll take it!
Man, that will let me go to ONE other place.
Alright!
Let's do it!
Let's do it! I'm excited!
I'm excited.
Alright, let's get outta here!
Beeeooom.
Alright.
*unique Markimoo sound effects*
Bam! Okay.
So how do we engage...
"Enable Galactic Travel", alright. That's cool.
But how do we engage... the hyperdrive?
"Open Galactic Map".
Hoooa...
Oooh!!
That's so COOL!
Wait, so this had three planets I only found...
Oh, this had four planets??
Whoa!!
oh...
Oh, that's cool.
Hang on! But that's not where-- how do I?
Okay, so...
Oh my god...
*in absolute rapture*
*nerding out*
*Adorable, excitement is contagious*
Oh my god!
Oh...
How would I do this??
This is so huge!
*setting free good energy vibes*
It's too big!
Oh it's too big!!
How would I be able to know??
Where anything is??
AAAgh...
Okay, so that was the other planet that I didn't go
to, "Ekremakimiri", but I can't go to that yet.
I gotta go to the next...
*space gasm*
So, I COULD go to like...
Oh, "Path towards galactic core".
But that's not even like the universal core!
Ooooh!
*Extremely excited* LET'S GO!!!
Oh, man...
(Breathe, Mark, BREATHE!)
WHOA!! I just went right through that planet.
Whuuuuut de heeeeck!
Oh, man!
*laughs* I guess this is cool??
I don't know what's happening.
I think someone is just shining a flashlight
right in front of my face.
I guess I can take a breather now!
Take a drink of water.
That might be good?
Whoa!
Oh-- Whaaaaat is thaaaaat???
WHOA, hey buddy.
How you doin'?
*in awe* It's an entirely new galaxy...
It's an entirely new-- NO, not new galaxy,
a new... it's a new solar system.
Is that an ocean planet?
*Breathes in excitedly*
WhOoh...
Do I have any reason-- I don't have a reason to go
to the space station just yet.
I need-- OH! I need to acquire an
antimatter recipe.
So I probably SHOULD go to the space station,
Augh...
But, Whoooaaa...
Whooooa!!!
HELLO!! *laugh*
HI!
What is your name?
"Jetsandedsosundade-- tesundade?"?? (close enough xD)
Jestsandesosunde.
Oh maaan...
Oh man... hey buddy...
Hey buuuddy!
Alright.
So I'm gonna go...
What??
What do you mean "Proximity"?
I'm not that close!
Oh...
OH!
OOOOOh, I guess I am that close.
I really did not realize that!
Oh that's cool!
Triangular.
I like it. It's a- it's a good change!
It's a neat-o change, I like it a lot.
"Bi-wa--tisha Ru--dei--vu".
Okay.
OOoOoh, it's so cool *mini boy mark*
I mean, I understand.
That a lot of this is gonna seem same,
because on the outside it may look different,
but functionally it's gonna be the same.
But still...
It's...
(not everyday we get to see the Markimoo at a loss for words xD)
It's cool.
It's really cool... I like it a looot...
"Nokubammeok-Imitr"??
I don't understand what that means!
Hello-- Ooooh... Hi??
Whoa...
Hello...?
Ah!
Okay?
You're different.
*worried*
"Korvax"...
I don't know the "Korvax" language???
How am I *laughs*
"As I approach the..." *reads text above*
"... what my scanner suggests are silicate elements."
What?
*Continues reading text*
Oh!
So...
You want something from me...
Well, I've got...
Platinum, I belie-- I don't know if I ha-- No I don't have platinum.
I've got some Heridium?
If you wanted that?
Alright.
Let's talk!
Let's talk in a language that you understand.
The language of money, which seems to be the
driving force in this entire universe.
Okay!
There you go.
"Mild disappointment" -- It's all I have.
Oh!
*laughs* It taught me what "rare" means, "warning",
because it wants more rare silicates.
I get it.
Alright.
Hi
Can I get the recipe for Warp Driveness?
Please.
Ah, I don't know any of that. Well that doesn't
help me.
This doesn't help me at all.
Ooh.
"L3"?
What?
"Star system scan"?
What the hell is a "Star system scan"??
I guess I gotta go out.
Maybe it was- maybe I wasn't supposed to go
to this just yet.
Probably.
Huh
Oookay, alright.
I'm gonna go then...
Goodbye!
Sayonara
Wait, was there something over there?
What's over here?
Oh, AtlasPass.
What the hell is an "AtlasPass"?
And what did I do this time?
Oohoh!
Yeah.
Well, I learned more words.
But from different languages so, yup.
Hmm... Ooh, that looks like it's got a lot of
storage space.
(It looks like a caterpillar, Mark :/  )
*at ship* I'm gonna get you eventually!!
Inbetween this and the next episode, I'm
gonna be doing a lot of farming
Autobot: Navigational data received.
Okay??
Okay...?
Ooh...
Aright, so where was that...
Please tell me...
Ah, dammit, but that's not the water planet??
THAT's the water planet...
Aw man... alright fine.
Gotta go to the manufacturing facility for
some reason.
I'm imagining that the manufacturing facility is
about warp drive technology and it's gonna-
-give me the stuff that I need to be
able to make it on my own.
Which by itself is fascinating; the ability
that I have to suddenly make everything
-in my own person, on my body, much like
in subnautica where you're just able to
point and shoot your magical crafting
device and then be able to get whatever
you want.
But whatever what can you do?
So, anyway.
Ah, man, though...
I guess this has SOME water.
Better than NO water.
"Ro-biu-sampto"...
Well I'm gonna rename that!
Wha-- does it got a mixture of like lava and water?
That's weird.
Weeeeeee!!
Niaaaauuuorm.
No, it's just red.
Whoa.
Well that's bizarre.
Oh.
This game would be cool to play in VR
by the way.
This game would be really cool.
Alright then, time to go to the manufacturing facility!
I don't have time to go anywhere else.
I'm gonna try to fly high, so that I can
go directly down into it and then way I can
save myself some time.
Nope, still far away
Come'on.
Come on!
Use de orbit of de earf.
It's not really an earth, but you know what I mean.
Jeez, that this is far away.
Okay, we're gonna pulse here because
it's takin'-- huUAAAAAH AH FUCK!
Whooooa, that was a pulse.
Holy shit.
No don't go down, don't go down
don't go down *panics*
What are you doing, what are you
doing-- JEEZEMS!
Christmas (is close again.)
What is that???
That's a big ass rock!!
*Rock: Thanks, Mark, I do try.*
Okay, no need for that.
Here we go again!
Aaah, shit shit-- where am I WHERE AM I GOING???
Stop pointing me away.
Pamela Anderson, this thing is so far!
Just go straight!
AAAAH!
Okay!
*giggles* We're getting closer.
Ohmygawd what's happening?
Why are we spinning now??
Why!!
Why are we spinning!!?
There's no need to spin!!
What is the point of this!!?
Why am I spinning!!
Okay, there we go.
I realize why I was spinning I was holding
down R1 instead of R2 *laughs at self*
And that just uh,
That makes you spin, if you didn't know xD
I'm an idiot.
Did you guys know that?
I'm an idiooot... Okay
But we made it.
Woooow.
Well that's weeeird.
Well that's cool!
Niiiice!
Burnin' up in the atmosphere-- Ooh, what is
thaaaat?
What is that???
That better not just be more Heridium,
I don't know WHAT it is but it doesn't LOOK like Heridium.
Okay.
Either way, we're close to the Manufacturing
Facility.
Aright.
Here we go.
Eeeeeeeh-boink!
I guess it kinda just picks landing places,
because I know I was closer to the front than that.
Oh.
What're you?
A "Bypass Chip"?
"Call starship".
I could make that, but I don't need to do that.
Ooooooh...
Neat-o!
Neeeat-o!
Cool-- WHOA!
Hey big guy!
Whoaaa, you're a big one!
Ooooh!
Niiiiice!
I don't know what I did, but I did it. Okay.
So now that I got this thing...
Let's see what awaits us in here.
"Steel Reinforced"??
What?
Can I bust through it?
Oh I can! Good.
Yup! I'm gonna get it. Don't worry.
Sentinels, what are you doing, I need to be in here!
This is important! Whoa, there's a lot
of you this time.
Whoa, that kinda hurts.
Oh, reload!
Jeezums, stop it!
There we go
Got him.
Where's the last one-- there you are.
Okay.
Got them...
There's the debris...
Ahh, I don't need any of that stuff.
Aright, where'd the last one go?
There it is.
Ah! There we go some value! Good good good.
Okay!
So almost through!
Don't know why they felt the need
to interrupt me.
OOOH!
Oh, goddammit, more???
*high pitch* How's there more??
Oh jeez, and the radiation levels
in here are intense!
Holy shit.
Well, that's not good!
Hang on!
Wait, don't die!!
I need to-- uoohh boy.
Goddammit, went the wrong way again.
"Life Support".
WOW, this Life Support is going down quick!
Plutonium...
Okay.
Ooh!
"Range Boost"? Okay... that's PART of the
technology I needed but not exactly.
Oh, hello!
HI!
Oh!
Hi!
Okay?
"Somewhere below my feet I hear..." *reads text above*
"... ESCAPE ATLAS FIND US NADA NADA"...
...What?
Okay. ¯_(⊙_ʖ⊙)_/¯
"Escape Atlas"?
"With this knowledge, I can create Warp Cells. The
final puzzle piece. I can now travel---"
Wait, so is it choice??
It's a choice to follow Atlas... what does "Atlas" want?
Who is Atlas???
WHAT is Atlas?
I mean, Atlas was the red orb material in the
beginning, but what--
*has sudden theory, but doesn't share with audience*
--does it want?
Did that say "Atlas find us" or "Atlas FOUND us"?
I'm confused.
Huh...
Now this is getting really interesting...
I'm not a 100% sure...
...anymore of the motivation, here.
Good! Korvax word for "korvax".
"Korvax" is the most important words, every
Korvax should know the word for Korvax.
Hello buddy, don't- don't kill me, please.
Aright.
Or don't try to kill me and then fail miserably.
Aright, so I gotta get outta here the
radiation is very bad right here.
*Calls out* This planet sucks!
I'm outta here!
I wanna go to the water planet =D
I don't even know if I have enough
to be able to lift off. Do I?
There we go.
Okay
So those are-- I'm out of Hyperdrive though. So, I'm gonna be stuck in this system until I'm able to get enough...
... to make another Warp cell, but the idea is
just to journey as quickly as you can...
... to the center of the galaxy, and that's
the center of the universe, I imagine.
*Spongebob impression*
Okay, so I need to find somewhere else to
go.
I'm gonna land on the water planet and then
that's gonna be the end of this episode here.
Huh...
Okay so, where am I ♪
Hellooo?
Is there a water planet around here?
That's a GREEN planet...
That's the shitty planet...
With lots of radiation.
That's not it.
*space melody in background* Ooh, that's a nice sound.
Why is that sound playing so much?
Well that's not it, either...
That's not it.
Well where'd it go???
That's- Ooh, is it actually...
Oh, wait wait!
Nope! THAT'S the shitty planet.
So that means...
Robo voice: Hostile scan detected
What??
What does THAT mean?
Robo voice: Warning, threat detected.
Robo voice: Hostile ships approaching.
That's not good!!!
Oh!
HI???
(butterfly, fly away♪)
Oh!
Hi!
*girly scream*
I'm not ready for this???
Oh jeez, I bare got started!
Oh boy, I don't know how to do this...
I'm no expert.
How would I be able to know!
Come a get-get some!!
Get some-- OH, BOY!
They want my cargo???
What a bunch of assholes!
What do you want with MY cargo??
Stop being dicks so much and then...
Eeaaaat a di-- OOOOH! SHIELD IS DOWN!
How the fuck...!!
*another girly scream*
I don't know how to do this??
Don't steal my cargo! I'm
outta here!
Oh fuck, I can't pulse jump!
Oh jeez, oh jeez... Do I f-- repair it??
Uuuuh ZINC!
There we go! Okay!
So I got that back up!
Holy shit.
Hooohey, that guy looks dablished!
Oh waaaait a minute.
Ow x12
Are you dead??
You better be dead! >:(
Kay, I'm gonna redo my shield.
There we go, there we go
there we go! Okay.
More, more, more!
Gimme gimme you!
Gimme you! Gimme you!
GIMME YOU!
Gimme fuel, gimme fire,
... GO DIE IN A FIRE!
Ah, dammit, I'm a terrible shot.
I don't know how to use this!
PS3 and it-- this isn't exactly the most
agile of ships.
Oh jeez...
Did I get him???
Emeril???
What????
Emeril??
Is that a person?
Did I just get a basket full of Emeril?
Oh boy... I'm tryin' to lead the target but
I don't *laughs*
I don't think that works-- Oh God
NooOOOOO!!!!
NOOOOOoOO!!
AAAAH, COME ON!
"Death by laser"???
(Sorry man xD)
AhhAAAAaaHhh!
What a bag of dick!
"Recover inventory at the location"-- OH.
GOD. DAMMIT!
Son of a bitch, my ship's not ready I didn't know
what the fuck I was doing!!!?
You sack of shit where's my
corpse!!
Where the fricky fu-- there!
Ooooooh...
"Journey Milestone" Oh, I died!
Goood for meee.
Uuuuugh.
That's a sack of crap.
Well!
That was new.
I didn't know that was gonna be a thing!
(Hoo, Markimoo is a pissed)
Fine! I gotta go-- UGH, I gotta go a minute over there
to get my shit back??
But I didn't know!!
How was I supposed to know how
that was supposed to work??
Why isn't there a "quick! Get your
shield back up" button???
Maybe there is! I wouldn't know!
You didn't tell me!
Son of a cack!
Aright, whatever it's fine.
(O rly xD)
It's fiiiiine.
It's alright don't worry about it. It's fine.
Did I get it?
Okay, I got it.
Yegh!
Theeeere's the water planet! That's
what I'm lookin' fore.
So now that I found the water planet,
I should be able to go have a good time underwater.
Okay!
On approach to-- wow, I don't see any land there.
Is there no land???
Oh, there's land!
WhoOOooa, there's barely any land,
but there is land.
Whoooooooh
Cooooooool!
Okay, this kinda makes up for the death,
even though I was already on the way here...
BEFORE I died, it's kinda cool to be here.
So, that's nice.
Very lovely.
Now let's see if it's actually worth being here
we don't know if it is.
Gimme some idea of where to go I'm gonna try
hit an outpost.
If there even is one on this planet.
Aaaaa! That's lovely!
Okaaaay, now we're getting somewhere!
Well, it's not really an Outpost.
But maybe there's a shopper terminal there?
Eh
Maybe, maybe, baby?
Aaaah, there's no shopping terminal.
"Full. Fair."
Huh.
Weather is "snowfall"???
Sure doesn't seem like snowfall.
Huh.
Oh! It's cold here.
Why's it cold?
Okay! So, now that I found this, I should be able to start
farming on this forest because,
it seems to have a good amount of
resources.
So I should be able to get what I need.
The only problem is that it's cold.
So I'm gonna find another base that has a shop
nearby and I'm gonna farm up a lot of money,
And then,
I'm gonna get what I need as-- oh, that's a knowledge
stone, but okay, we can ignore that for now.
And then, I'm gonna find what I need in terms of
getting the Hyperdrive in order.
But that's all gonna take place in the next episode, so.
Thank you everybody so much for watching, I am
still having fun, even-- you know, the death,
It's fine, death happens, I get it. Now, I'll be on
the lookout for pirates and,
I'll hopefully upgrade my dang ship, so that I can
fight back because,
I was severely outclassed. But that's besides the
point, because I am gonna get better.
So, thank you again, and as always!
I will see YOU, in the next video!
Buh-bye!